IS HERE WITH THE MOST OUTRAGEOUS
COMMENTS OF THE WEEK.
BUT FIRST MY OPENING STATEMENT.
THE MAN LEADING THE FBI'S
INVESTIGATION INTO HILLARY
CLINTON'S USE OF A PERSONAL
EMAIL SERVER AND RUSSIAN
INTEREST FORCE IN THE 2016
ELECTION TESTIFIED BEFORE
CONGRESS THIS WEEK.
AGENT PETER STRZOK THE
PERSONIFICATION OF THE RIGHTEOUS
LEFT THINKING THEY KNOW BETTER
THAN THE REST OF US WAS A
COMPOSITE OF POMPOUS ARROGANCE,
INDIGNANT.
SARCASTIC.
SMUG, CONDESCENDING.
DEFIANT AND UNAPOLOGETIC.
STRZOK SEEMS TO SHARE CARDINAL
COMEY'S AFFECTATION OF BEING A
SELFLESS SERVANT OF THE PEOPLE
THOUGH HE SEEMS TO HOLD ALL IN
CONTEMPT.
STRZOK IS ALSO A PERSONIFICATION
OF THE DEEP STATE WHERE FASCISM
RULES.
WHERE PEOPLE IN POWER DON'T WARE
WHAT YOU THINK.
BUT INSTEAD DECIDE THEY KNOW
BETTER.
THEY KNOW WHAT'S RIGHT, AND THEN
THEY IMPLEMENT IT.
BUT STRZOK ISN'T BIASED.
HE SAID SO HIMSELF.
>> AFTER MONTHS OF
INVESTIGATION, THERE SIMPLY IS
NO EVIDENCE OF BIAS IN MY
PROFESSIONAL ACTIONS.
JUDGE JEANINE: FOR ME IT WAS ONE
HAVE EVER SEEN.
HIS OWN TEXT EXCHANGES BETRAY
HIS DENIALS.
HE AND HIS MISTRESS LISA PAGE
CALLED DONALD TRUMP AN FING
IDIOT, LOATHESOME, AN HE THOSE -
IDIOT, LOATHESOME, AN HE THOSE A
IDIOT, LOATHESOME, AN HE THOSE N
ENORMOUS D.
FOR OF ANY YOU WHO DON'T BELIEVE
YOUR LYING EARS.
TAKE A LISTEN TO THIS.
>> FOR 10 DAYS BEFORE THE
INVESTIGATION BEGAN WHICH THE
DEPARTMENT YOU WORK FOR SAYS
NOTHING WAS DONE BEFORE JULY 31.
HIS PRESIDENCY WOULD BE.
BETWEEN JULY 31 AND ALL 8.
HOW MANY INTERVIEWS DID YOU
CONDUCT RELATED TO THE ALLEGED
COLLUSION BETWEEN RUSSIA AND THE
INVESTIGATED, HAD HE
INTERVIEWED.
>> THE COUNSEL OF THE FBI BASED
ON THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
EQUITIES DIRECTED ME NOT TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
ONGOING INVESTIGATION INTO
RUSSIAN ATTEMPTS TO INTERFERE.
JUDGE JEANINE: DIRECTED NOT TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS BY THE
COUNSEL FOR THE FBI.
WHY IS THIS IMPORTANT?
WHY WOULD IT BE IMPORTANT TO
WHY?
BECAUSE NOTHING HAPPENED TO EVEN
BEGIN AN INVESTIGATION.
THEY MADE UP A DATE, AND THEY
MADE UP A REASON.
DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS KNEW THE
DANGER ZONE THEY WERE IN, AND
SO AND
SO -ND
BROKE OUT IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
>> HE SAID HE HAS BEEN
INSTRUCTED BY THE FBI NOT TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION.
>> MR. CHAIRMAN, IS IT NOT
APPROPRIATE TO ALSO INTERJECT
IS A TOOL OF THE HOUSE TO THE
HAS BEEN ADVISED NOT TO ANSWER
HILL FROM THERE.
>> MR. CHAIRMAN, PLEASE.
>> YOU KNOW, CHAIRMAN, THE
HARASSMENT OF THE WITNESS.
BUT MORE THAN THAT, IT WAS A
MICROCOSM OF WHAT THE LEFT HAS
DONE WHEN THEY WANT TO SHUT DOWN
THE RIGHT.
THE PENT-UP RAGE AND PANDEMONIUM
IS AN EXAMPLE OF HOW ANGRY THE
LEFT IS.
WHILE THE REPUBLICAN DEDUCTED
THEMSELVES IN A GENTEEL MANNER,
THE DEMOCRATS CLAIMING
PARLIAMENT ARE YOU POINTS OF
ORDER BLEW THEIR COLLECTIVE
GASKETS.
STRZOK SAID HE'S FOLLOWING FBI
PROTOCOL.
THEY TOLD HIM NOT TO SAY
A LIAR AND IS ALLOWED TO ANSWER
THE QUESTION THAT GOES TO THE
BASIS OF THIS ABSURD
INVESTIGATION INTO DONALD
TRUMP'S ALLEGED CONNECTION WITH
RUSSIA.
WHEN GIVEN THE GREEN LIGHT.
HERE IS THE ANSWER.
>> BETWEEN JULY 31 AND 2016 AND
AUGUST 6, 2016, HOW MANY WITNESS
INTERVIEWED DID YOU CONDUCT AS
PART OF THE' RUSSIA WILL STRUM
CAMPAIGN ALLEGED COLLUSION
CAMPAIGN.
>> WE WAITED ALL THE TIME FOR
THAT ANSWER.
JUDGE JEANINE: THE TEXT, QUOTE,
I WANT TO BELIEVE THE PATH YOU
THREW OUT FOR CONSIDERATION IN
ANDY'S OFFICE THAT THERE IS NO
WAY HE GETS ELECTED.
BUT I AM AFRAID WE CAN'T TAKE
THAT RISK IT'S LIKE THE
INSURANCE POLICY IN THE UNLIKELY
EVENT YOU DIE BEFORE YOU ARE 40.
STRZOK WASN'T TRYING TO PREVENT
TRUMP FROM WINNING.
WHAT HE WAS DOING WAS EVEN
WORSE.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT HAVING A
PLAN TO EFFECTIVELY
DISENFRANCHISE THE VOTERS WHO
ELECTED TRUMP.
SHOULD TRUMP WIN.
FORGET DEMOCRACY, FORGET THE
HE SAID SO HIMSELF.
IN A TEXTING TO HIS MISTRESS.
IF THIS CANDIDATE OF CHOICE
DIDN'T WIN.
THE ONE HE HELPED AVOID CRIMINAL
LIABILITY.
HE WAS GOING TO ABUSE THE TOUR
WE ENTRUSTED HIM TO INSURE THAT
IT DIDN'T MATTER.
IF THE UNTHINKABLE WERE TO
HAPPEN, HIS INSURANCE POLICY
IS THE RUSSIA COLLUSION
LIARS, LEAKS AND LIBERALS.
DETAILING THE POWER STRUCTURE,
TRYING TO BRING THE PRESIDENT
DOWN.
THE BOOK HIT STORE SHELVES
TUESDAY.
BUT YOU CAN STILL PREORDER IT ON
AMAZON AND BARNES & NOBLE.COM.
DON'T FORGET TO TELL ME WHAT YOU